ce mardi 25 juillet un nouveau
dispositif d'accueil du centre des
finances de Mantes-la-Jolie a été
présenté la sous-préfecture accueille
désormais des guichets d'accueil dans
ses locaux une mesure qui fait suite aux
violences urbaines déclenchée par la
mort de Naël le 27 juin dernier une
partie du centre des finances publiques
de Mantes-la-Jolie avait alors été
incendie dans la nuit du vendredi 30
juin au samedi 1er juillet des dégâts
qui représentent plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros alors les diagnostics
sont lancés les devis sont lancés
il y aura ensuite des travaux de
nettoyage de réfection électrique de
réfection d'un couloir qui a été détruit
par l'incendie et ça prendra plusieurs
semaines sinon plusieurs mois la
sous-préfecture de Mantes-la-Jolie a mis
à disposition trois guichets pour le
service des impôts des particuliers ça a
été un geste tout à fait spontané et
normal entre service de ce prêter
secours dans ces circonstances qui sont
dramatiques surtout nous avons pensé aux
usagers de Mantes-la-Jolie qui était
obligé d'aller jusqu'au bureau pour UER
leur démarche un accueil de proximité
est ouvert du 8h45 à midi à la
sous-préfecture de Mantes-la-Jolie et
l'après-midi de 13h à 15h45 seulement
sur rendez-vous